we have other videos on individual
techniques for factoring quadratics but
I would like to do in this video is get
some practice figuring out which
technique to use so I'm going to write a
bunch of quadratic so I encourage you to
pause the video try to see if you can
factor that quadratic yourself before I
work through it with you
so the first quadratic is 6x squared
plus 3x so pause and see if you can
factor this so this one might jump out
at you that both of these terms here
have a common factor both of them are
divisible by 3 6 is divisible by 3 and
so is 3 and both of them are divisible
by X so you can factor out a 3x so if
you factor out a 3x 6x squared divided
by 3x you're going to have a 2x left
over there and then 3x divided by 3x
you're going to have a 1 and that's
about as much as we can actually factor
it and you can verify that these two
expressions are the same if you
distribute the 3x 3x times 2x is 6x
squared 3x times 1 is 3x and that's all
we would do we would be done that's all
you can do to really factor that and as
we'll see in this example trying to
factor out a common factor was all we
had to do but as we'll see in future
examples that's usually a good first
step do all of check whether the terms
have a common factor and if they do it
never hurts to factor that out so let's
do another example let's say I have the
quadratic 4x squared minus 4x minus 48
pause the video and try to factor that
as much as you can alright so the first
thing you might have noticed is that
there is a common factor amongst the
terms all of them are divisible by 4 4
is clearly divisible by 4 and 48 is also
divisible by 4 so let's factor a 4 out
this would be the same thing is 4 times
x squared minus X minus 12 I just
divided each of these by 4 and I
factored it out you can distribute the 4
and verify that these two expressions
are the same now are we done well no we
can factor what we have inside the
parentheses we can factor this further
now how would we do that so over here
the key realization is all right I have
a 1 as the coefficient on my second
degree term I've written it in standard
form where I have the second degree and
then if there's a first degree term and
then I have my constant term or my zero
degree term and if I have a 1
coefficient right over here then I say
okay are there two numbers whose sum
equals the coefficient on the first
degree term on the X term so are there
two numbers that add up to negative one
you didn't see a 1 here before but we
it's implicit there negative x is the
same thing as negative 1x so there are
two numbers a plus B that is equal to
negative 1 and whose product is equal to
negative 12 this is a technique that we
do in other videos and here the key is
to realize that hey maybe we can use it
here so a times B is equal to negative
12 and there's a couple of key
realizations here it's like okay if I
have two numbers and their product is
going to be a negative that means one of
them that means are going to have
different signs one's going to be
positive and one's going to be negative
if they have the same sign then this
would be positive so let's think about
the factors of 12 and especially think
about them in terms of different sign
combinations so you could think about 1
and 12 and whether you're thinking about
negative 1 and 12 negative 1 plus 12
would be positive 11 if you want the
other way around if you went negative 12
and one would be negative 11 but either
way that doesn't work 2 & 6 negative 2 &
6 would be 4 negative 6 and 2 would be
negative 4 so that doesn't work 3 & 4
let's see negative 3 & 4 would be
positive 1 but 3 and negative 4 works
out you add these two together you take
their product you clearly get negative
12 and then you add them together you
get negative 1 so we can write inside
the parentheses so let me write so
there's going to be 4 times so we can
factor that as 2 binomials the first is
going to be X plus the first is going to
be X plus 3 and then the next is going
to be we could say X plus negative 4 we
could say X
- four and we're done and if any of this
seems intimidating to you I encourage
you to watch the videos on introduction
to factoring polynomials the key here is
to recognize the method so once again at
first try to factor out any common
factors we did that in both examples
then we saw here hey if we have a
leading 1 coefficient here on the second
degree term and we have it written in
standard form well let's think of two
numbers that add up to this coefficient
and whose product is equal to the
constant term and in this case it was 3
and negative 4 we were able to factor it
this way we proved that in other videos
let's do another example we can't get
enough practice and like always pause
the video and see if you can work
through it yourself 3x squared + 30 + 75
all right I'm assuming you had a go at
it so you might immediately see that all
the terms are divisible by 3 so let's
factor 3 out so it's gonna be 3 times x
squared + hope so this should be an X
here my apologies pause the video again
and see if you can do it with lookit now
that I wrote the actual the right thing
there alright so as you imagine it's
nice to factor out a 3 first so it's 3
times x squared plus 10x plus 25 and so
you might immediately say all right well
let's use the technique we head here we
have a leading one coefficient it's
written in standard form can I think of
two numbers that add up to 10 so a plus
B is equal to 10 and whose product a
times B is equal to 25 and this would
work and if you look at the factors of
25 you'd say all right well you know
this thing here is positive this is
positive so I'm dealing with two
positive numbers and we get 25 it's
either 1 + 25 or 5 & 5 & 5 & 5 match
this 5 plus 5 is equal to 10 5 times 5
is equal to 25 and so just using the
exact technique we just did you'd say
okay this is 3 times and the stuff in
parentheses would be X plus 5 times X
plus 5 or you could say 3 times X plus 5
squared so some of you might have
immediately said well I don't have to do
that exact technique I could have
immediately recognized this as a perfect
square because I have a square constant
right over here and that's a good sign
that hey maybe I should explore whether
this is going to be a perfect square
polynomial so this is a perfect square
and if I were to take the square root of
it and this coefficient is twice that
square root well that's a good sign that
I'm probably dealing or that I am
dealing with a perfect square but either
way whether you recognize it as a
perfect square or whether you use the
technique that we use in the second
problem either one of those would get
you to the appropriate answer